[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jalen rose
espn nba analyst uh you want to join us
crying next tuesday night there
no no i've been doing a lot of crime
recently unfortunately dan had a few
deaths in the family
so no crying for me not right now not
voluntary all right
uh good to have you on and uh what
does the word yoka mean yo
used to be strong diesel
um having a great physique
physically imposing
did you ever hear it uh used for a dunk
like he got yoked on
i did like when i was really young
that's
when like uh and i was like 70s early
terminology
but you know what else it's funny to
hear um
in modern day slang and i love rasheed
wallace that's my brother
won a championship with the pistons by
the way my guy but it's funny to me when
i hear people
believe that he created ball don't lie
like people weren't saying that in the
early 70s
[Laughter]
i never heard the expression you know
getting yoked on i
i just thought it meant that you had
like you were muscle bound
anytime somebody gets dunked on there's
an expression for it that's been used at
least once
you know especially some bad puns also
i'm sure
what's the worst dunk that you ever got
posterized on
i've never been dunked on because i
didn't play defense
and i understood the geometry of the
floor and i was a student of the game
and
played attention to players launch point
and stuff like that
you know is this a right hand player
jumping off his left leg can he go off
two feet can he go out like
you got to calculate all of that stuff
oh you got to whack that arm or whack
that shoulder
you know there's a lot of footage of me
getting scored on but ain't no footage
we had bashan the other day and i forgot
that he was with toronto when kobe put
up 81.
like he quickly pushed the blame on to
other players
he said he goes i kept looking up at the
scoreboard and i go
how's this guy scoring five points at a
time here because kobe bryant is one of
the all-time greats at basketball and
you know one of the things i actually
now appreciate about being a part of
that game
is the opportunity to continue to
celebrate his legacy talk about his
legacy talk about that game
and really acknowledged for people what
the mamba mentality
is and it it's embodied in that game
he didn't have any highlights in that
game
it wasn't when you watch like the
celebration of that game
you're gonna like see him get a
breakaway two-hand dunk
you're gonna see him make like a 500
threes on me
but like you're not going to see like
any
any killer crossover any dunk on
somebody
and the reason why i like to point that
part out is because
that's what happens when you're really
locked in and the other thing is he
never
talked trash see one thing about and i'm
a trash talker and was always a trash
talker that
once you start talking a lot of trash
then you don't necessarily get to 50
or 60 or 70 or 80 because people start
to load up on you start to try to follow
you
and things of that nature so that game
really embodies his all-time
greatness and uh at least we kept them
under a hundred we can't we'll
we can't we kept will's record safe for
him he's uh jaylen rose he'll appear on
nba countdown tonight at eight eastern
leading into the mavs clippers game six
on espn let's start there what do you
think happens tonight
i believe the clippers find a way to win
this series and they better
because when you put together kawhi and
pg
that's that's the version of what the
lakers were doing with
lebron and a.d kawhi top two or three
player paul george top
12 player you can't go from losing in
the second round to the nuggets when you
were up 3-1
changing coaches in dog rivers now the t
lou and then getting bounced in the
first round
by a one-man all-nba show in the
previous game where two guys scored in
double figures
and they put bovine out there and and
and
carlisle did a terrific job of making an
adjustment of playing a lot of zone i
remember
watching uh his dallas mavs do that in
the finals against lebron they brought a
lot of zone
brought a lot of porzingis using their
size but i still just
with each team with each road team
winning the game
winning every game this series i think
the clippers find a way to force a game
seven
i think they still find a way to win
this series because luca just overall
just doesn't have enough offensive help
okay i know that the lakers will always
garner headlines in los angeles and
rightly so but if the clippers bow out
without an excuse of somebody being
injured like what's more
i don't know disappointing embarrassing
the lakers bowing out in the first round
or the clippers so here's what's more
disappointing
the clippers bowing out after watching
the lakers get
bowed out just think about this you get
a chance as a clipper
two nights ago three nights ago to go to
bed 10 feet tall
like you know what lakers just lost to
phoenix
you know if we go out and play well
against the mavs
we can advance and we can be the team of
la
that's still participating and i can't
front dan
who would have thought a couple of years
into adding
firepower with the lakers and the
clippers that we wouldn't get them in a
playoff series
we didn't get them last year we ain't
not we're not going to get them this
year
so it'll be disappointing for the clip
it it just reminds me it's like being a
lions fan it's like
clippers fans can't have nice things you
know
as soon as they have a little
expectation we start to believe in them
start to put them on prime time tv
um and all of a sudden they come up
short but but here's the
here's one of the roster issues with the
clippers i've been saying this all
season
they have good young talent like a man
and i just wish each of their league
guards was one player
like like the intellect and leadership
of rajon rondo
the the confidence of the offensive
confidence of reggie jackson the
athleticism of man the shooting
uh uh uh like of the canard
like i just wish all of them was one
player but since they're four or five
players you end up looking at the end of
the game at kawhi when he takes a three
when he's the only one of the only
players on the team that didn't shoot
from 40 this year
and they close out the game and they
don't look well but i'm still gonna pick
the clippers to win this series
but let's celebrate lucas greatness you
don't just see guys out there getting
40s and 14s like he's been doing
the reason why the lakers were
eliminated is
injury a.d plays the entire seven games
the lakers win this series
but injuries have been at part of ads
history
just like that part of mb's history
they've been a part of chris paul's in
history that just happens with certain
players um
it's why you don't want to be a seed
it's why seven seed has never won the
championship
because the lakers would have been
required to beat a two seed a three seed
and likely a one seed you know and and
that's just tough sledding and you have
no rule for error
when he shoots a jumper in the early uh
before
the end of the regular season he comes
down on the scoreboard he twists his
ankle
you know you have no room for error gets
injured hurts his groin have no room for
error
and the other thing i must say um i give
phoenix a lot of credit
and shout out to monty williams for his
player development with his young guys
and integrating chris paul and devin
booker was outstanding
um taking over the game and had had a
big time first half
but lebron looks fatigued out there we
can't ignore that the last
two or three games in particular in the
second half there's a lot of footage
of four on three breaks 504 breaks with
lebron trailing the play he's looking at
the rest
he looking a little bewildered and
looking like the old man out there at
the run
yeah and that happens when the team
looks faster they look younger and they
look up like
like they have an opportunity to close
you out and that's what the sons did
what kind of changes do you think the
lakers should or will make
so here's how the nba offseason works
for the media
every every player is now going to be
linked to the
lakers or to the knicks so as soon as
dame lillard does a tweet
all of the medias don't put them on the
lakers or the next there
there's no knee jerk move for the lakers
um you're not changing your gm you're
not changing your coach
and you want clearly want lebron and a d
back you know there may be a move there
if you try to figure out if you want to
do something with kuzma or
choose not to bring back schroeder but
you have his bird rights
so it's probably in your best interest
but either way like
there's no true knee jerk move but they
will make some roster moves but
you still need lebron james and a.d to
be the best players you still need them
to be the driving forces
and you build the role players around
your superstars not the other way around
if you were damien lillard what would
you do
that was dane dalla he has total
around 400 million signed in contracts
um he's actually probably my favorite
player
um the only guy to have a 50 10 assists
and
10 made threes in the game has become d
quest for former lead portland in the
playoffs each year
he's on every commercial got got he's on
every commercial but they
ain't got more brands don't you can
never say you can't get
endorsements in a small market dave got
every commercial
and he has a rap album i believe that a
multiple rap albums i just think
uh they probably changed coaches and
terry stotts and how about this for a
noble idea
how about fire terry scott if they do so
and by the way i think terry stotts did
a great job so i'm not calling for him
to be fired
i just feel like when nurkish comes out
and said what he said after the game
and you've been there as long as he have
and they've had um so many first-round
exes i think he just becomes
the the change but how about in portland
you do what boston did
you let go of terry stotts from coaching
and you make him the president
how about that what a noble thing what a
noble thing
and and who did better in their tenure
as a head coach terry scott or brad
stevens
but either way i think um they started
listening to calls for cj mccullum
yep but you do whatever makes dame happy
is what you do
and if i'm dame dollar i think i still
want to be in portland
at least one more season because i think
he may have a chance to help them pick a
coach
help them decide what to do possibly
with cj mccollum
and nurkic and uh have his fingerprints
on the roster
yeah i i mean i feel bad that he's 30
and you know at some point you start to
look around
and go am i ever going to play in a big
game am i going to play
for a championship here and
i just played in the big game last night
they lost
it was a first round game i mean that's
not
a big game they was in the western
conference finals two years ago and got
swept
yeah yeah here
here's what i i i just want to caution
all media
fans and i've been saying this for years
let's not get into the ring
counting then you force players to start
ring chasing
now everybody wants bradley bill to
leave washington
wants dame lillard to leave portland
we're gonna start looking at league pass
and
it's going to be like eight teams with
all of the all-stars
maybe less than that no i i hope beale
stays in washington and i hope that
dame stays in portland i just don't know
what that frustration must be like for
him where i mean he made the tweet
you know the nipsy hustle tweet last
night like how
how you know dedicated you know should i
be here
so that i don't know and i know it's
after a loss there but i
i would just like to see him get an
opportunity
to show everybody just how great he is
instead of just highlights on
sportscenter
so giannis is showing us how great he is
if they lose to the net in this round
people are going to be saying the exact
same thing about him
giannis shouldn't have stayed i don't
know why he resigned
if i was giannis i would go to dallas he
should go to miami
like and then in a couple of years you
know what we're going to be doing saying
the same thing about luca oh yeah
i don't know what's going on we then
we'll be saying it about zion
should zion resign then we're going to
do it about john marant
should john murray like i just
don't want players fans and media to get
into this
idea that the best team
and or the best player supposed to win
the championship every single year
or be the favorite because that's
unrealistic are you in new york
right now on the street you know you
hear those subways you know that just
sounds different
you you hear the pans on the street meat
behind me
see in l.a they have fruit on the street
out here they have street meat
do you what do people say to you on the
streets in new york what up dole
give the people what they want
you be chris on tv you got the best
hairline in the game
i know somebody named jalen how was it
like to have kobe score 81 on it
i love the fat five i wore black socks
because of you
uh the list goes on and on and on it's
all off yeah that's pretty good
you know because new york fans they can
be kind of mean so i'm glad that they're
saying nice things about you
oh yeah that's all i love i'm a man of
the people you know how we do it
of course i know that uh hey great to
talk to you and uh we'll be watching
tonight
uh you can see jalen and company nba
countdown at eight
eastern leading into the mavs clippers
game six on espn
jay have a great weekend thanks for
joining us i appreciate the level check
me out each thursday renaissance man
podcast and i write a column for the new
york post
appreciate the love thank you bro that's
uh jaylen rose take a break
play of the day coming up next